ragot 3 6 6 2 0 game over
ça y est l'intelligence artificielle de
google a gagné a en tout cas aujourd'hui
elle en est à trois victoires contre 0
il reste encore deux parties voir si ça
va faire un 5 0 et on peut se demander
si l'intelligence artificielle de google
alpha go est vraiment intelligente mais
pour ça il va revenir à 1996 97 ou deep
blue qui est l intelligence artificielle
de dilemme a battu garry kasparov aux
échecs à ce moment là personne ne sait
sauter de joie en disant ça y est
l'intelligence artificielle est plus
intelligente que l'homme parce que d'un
côté
l'intelligence artificielle ne savait
jouer aux échecs à cette époque et qui
plus est elles jouaient pas forcément
comme l'homme honteuse vais lui
apprendre beaucoup de règles des
techniques qu'elle avait joué une telle
que c'est toutes les fin de partie et
c'est dévaler des connaissances inculte
et qui a été sur humaine déjà pour
commencer du coup elle avait pas
vraiment appris tout cas pas comme
l'homme et ça ça m'amène à parler de
l'expérience de la chambre chinoise par
john soeur qui dit que imaginez que vous
êtes dans une pièce dans une salle
fermée et que vous avez un bouquin qui
de chinois qui liste des phrases
classique de chinois et les réponses
classiques là ces questions maintenant
vous demande de discuter avec un chinois
qui en dehors de la salle et qui vous
envoient des messages écrits la sq
yvonne sort c'est que ce que vous pouvez
faire c'est prendre ce message en compte
trouvé son équivalent dans le bouquin
sont identiques et renvoyer la réponse
que le bouquin dit de renvoyer et ainsi
aux yeux du chinois à l'extraire de la
salle vous aurez l'air intelligent vous
aurez l'air en tout cas chinois de
parler comme un chinois
or en fait vous comprenez rien aux
chinois et ça adonne sort le disait
c'était l'équivalent de laiterie de
l'intelligence artificielle
l'intelligence artificielle en tout cas
celle de l'époque faisait exactement ça
elle ne comprenait pas forcément tous
les tenants et les aboutissants de ce
qu'elle faisait mais elle a appliqué les
règles combiner deux chiffres et à la
fin donnait sa conclusion
et ça aujourd'hui ça ressort un peu
aujourd'hui aussi sur alpha go certains
disent que alpha go ne fait que calculer
des nombres et en déduire quelque chose
à partir de règles de calcul uniquement
mais ça je pense que c'est très très
vache de dire ça c'est bon c'est vrai
mais c'est un petit peu pincé un petit
peu détourner le débat parce que la
manière dont alpha yago réfléchissent en
fait très très très proches quand on
regarde les la méthode par laquelle
alpha gohari a réussi à devenir aussi
forte
eh bien on se rend compte qu'il en fait
c'est très proche de la manière dont
l'homme arrive à être très fort en tout
cas l'homme en général mais plutôt du
single arrive à être très très fort au
jeu de go c'est à dire que à lagos qu'il
a fait s'il a commencé à jouer certaines
parties temps en temps il y avait un
mètre à côté de lui qu'il dise qu'il
disait ah ça c'est pas bien où ça c'est
bien puis puis elle apprenait quelques
rudiments du jeu de go et puis après il
a commencé à jouer
belle même bon elle souffre qu'elle n'a
pas besoin de jouer contre quelqu'un
d'autre elle peut soulever contre
elle-même et même jouait beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup construit elle-même et
en jouant j'enjoins elle a réussi à un
ferrer à comprendre quelles étaient les
bons mouvements quels étaient les
mauvais mouvement qu'elle est ainsi et
elles étaient les situations où elle
était dans une situation avantageuse ou
qu'elle était une situation qu'il était
plutôt désavantageuse etc vont lui
enseigner aussi un petit peu de théorie
on lui a dit que c'était bien d'essayer
de d'explorer les coûts qui avait l'air
prometteur ce qu'on appelle la recherche
monte carlo du jour envoie donc vers les
vidéos de david loire et sur science
étonnante et de thomas kaboré sur
patience les ex ensuite deux ex en vidéo
sur le jeu de go moi je vais pas du tout
parler les shows de bourges et appris
les règles avec eux je connais rien du
tout j'ai jamais joué plus apprendre du
go par contre ce sur quoi j'aimerais
vraiment 6 tc que la manière dont alpha
boas a pris est vraiment très très
similaire à la manière dont l'homme
apprend vraiment on a quelques règles
théoriques en tête c'est ce qui est de
recherche d'arbres on a un professeur
qui nous dit faire si vous faire ça
c'est pas bien et puis une fois qu'on a
dépassé le maître
on va explorer par nous mêmes on va
jouer par nous mêmes on va tenter des
coups par nous mêmes
et puis on va inférées de notre
expérience
ce qui est bien ce qui est pas bien et
ça c'est exactement sur lequel fargo a
fait et à partir du moment où on se rend
compte qu'il a fallu à des raisonnements
qui sont très proche de celui de l'homme
pour ensuite faire le jeu de go alors il
est vraiment temps de dire que dans son
intelligence est elle vraie c'est une
vraie intelligence artificielle
en fait quand je dis ça j'ai une vision
ultra anthropocentrique de
l'intelligence pourquoi est ce que
l'intelligence devraient être définis
par rapport à celle de l'homme n'y at il
pas une autre vente d'intelligence mais
sauf que sur des jeux comme le jeu de go
en tout cas aujourd'hui on ne connaît
pas de meilleure façon de réfléchir que
celle de loeb donc c'est pas si
surprenant que alpha go en soient venus
à réfléchir comme loeb mais sur d'autres
problèmes
l'homme est stupide et du coup sûr
certaine façon de réfléchir sur certains
problèmes là c'est une chance
des machines est déjà largement au
dessus de celle de dames qu'à ça je
pense que c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
prendre en compte et bien se dire que
par exemple quand il s'agit de faire des
calculs sur l'évolution de l'univers est
pas la machine est déjà beaucoup plus
intelligente que nous l affaire des
choses que nous n'arrivent pas à faire
en fait y'a pas que sur le jeu de go que
l'intelligence artificielle a commencé à
résonner comme l'inde par exemple en
2012 l'intelligence artificielle de
l'autre intelligence artificielle de
google diploma hnd à inventer
d'elle-même le concept de chat en
regardant des étiquettes de vidéos
youtube genre de choses oui forcément il
ya eu pas mal de l'image de chats et
donc c'est assez fou de voir qu'elle a
inventé d'allumer le concept de chats
alors comment est ce qu'on sait qu'elle
a inventé le concept de chats bas de
même façon que l'on peut savoir ce qui
se passe nous dans notre tête nous a
fait passer un essai ce dilemme c'est à
dire on a regardé quels étaient les
neurones de sons et de son cerveau parce
que l'intelligence artificielle de
google est un réseau nooï en fait ce
sont des réseaux de neurones totalement
simuler donc totalement virtuel et quand
je vais parler ensuite dire m c'est bien
sûr une analogie dans lequel étaient les
neurones qui s'activait lorsqu on lui
montrait une image de chats et ce qui
est assez fou c'est qu'on peut lui
montrer les images de chats dans toutes
les positions toutes les couleurs de
tous types de chat très souvent c'était
les mêmes normes qui s'activait et ses
neurones ne s'active et pas autre cas
pas ensemble lorsqu'on y montrait une
photo qui n'était pas une photo de chat
de qu'elle avait vraiment dans sa danse
attaque toute pensée de rhodes un
concept qui ressemblait beaucoup au
concept de chat ce qui est fou c'est
qu'elle a inventé ça d'elle même pensé
mon l'a pas dit ça ne l'a pas dit ça
c'est un chat on veut juste montrer des
photos et d'un mois ces dix tonnes mais
ce truc qu'il ya un truc qui me sens va
pas tu as plusieurs endroits et bon je
vais appeler ça un chauffard il n'a pas
appelé sacha il ajuste déterminer une
connexion réseau
un ensemble de route qui allait
s'activer lorsqu'il voyait cette image
et ça c'est vraiment fou et c'est ça
veut dire aussi que l'indigence
artificielle elle et va être assez
difficile à reconnaître petit à petit
elle va être à s'immiscer de plus en
plus dans votre vie
et elle va nous paraître être comme une
personne à qui l'on parle et c'est le
peuple par contre ça ne veut pas dire
que ça va être forcément un robot parce
que je regardais l'émission de france 2
hier avec ce débat sur l'intelligence
artificielle et les robots et puis ça a
parlé énormément de robots humanoïdes
donc les robots humanoïdes
ils ont peut-être une place importante à
jouer au japon chez les personnes âgées
dans un avenir assez proche mais je vais
me semble que dans notre quotidien nous
la plupart des gens ça va être ça qu'on
va rencontrer ce mois en france
rencontrer comme l'intelligence
artificielle c'est l'intelligence
artificielle qui est implanté dans les
ordinateurs et dans les téléphones en
fait elle est déjà là haut je parle au
futur en fait je devrais passer au
parler au passé
les intrigues l'intelligence
artificielle s'est immiscé dans notre
vie quotidienne
et c'est pas que série c'est aussi
google c'est le moteur de recherche est
plein de l'application qui utilise comme
ça des réseaux de neurones pour mieux
communiquer mieux nous faire comprendre
mieux nous donner accès à internet et à
plein de fonctionnalités qu'on trouve
sur nos os à travers les nouvelles
technologies
moi j'écoute énormément de trucs de pro
de professeurs par les deux genres de
choses de professeurs de référence
artificielle et de travail allant entre
eux sur deux ans qui ne machine qui est
un excellent podcast en anglais mais
excellent que je conseille vivement
et donc sur peter king machine à ryan
adams lui souligne fait que pour lui il
existe déjà des robots tueurs
par exemple une mine antipersonnel c'est
quelque chose qui n'a plus besoin de
l'homme pour détecter et tuer ou blesser
parce que parfois c'est pas forcément de
dessus et c'est peut-être plus d'amputer
les gens ce qui a vraiment horrible elle
n'a pas besoin de quiconque pour les
affaires savent juste à attendre tel un
tel un prédateur enfuis sous le sol
sa victime pour la détruire complètement
bon il mine antipersonnel ça commence à
vraiment date et on est capable de la
fin on est capable malheureusement j'ai
envie de dire de faire beaucoup mieux
depuis
des missiles ciblés qui peuvent dévier
leurs trajectoires ajuster leurs traits
victoire en fonction de ce qu'elle voit
ça c'est vraiment des robots tueurs déjà
que et donc quand les gens disent il
faut légiférer sur les robots tueurs du
futur non faut légiférer sur les robots
du passé et du coup du présent je pense
que les investissements notamment de
l'armée américaine à ce sujet sont
vraiment stupéfiant mais on va avant de
faire de quoi faire peur quoi je pense
que j'ai bien plus peur de des robots
tueurs qui existe déjà et moraux mais
des intelligences artificielles tueur de
technologie pour tuer de l'armée
américaine que du terminator ou ex
machina club bon après je comprends que
la télé parle de sens et les trucs qui
capturent l'imagination donc forcément
ça fait plus vu en tout cas que qu'on le
veuille ou non la fusion sans artificiel
va prendre quoi
encore une fois je parle au futur il
faut que je parle pas c'est la vision
artificielle a pris une place dominante
dans notre vie quotidienne
elle est vraiment déjà partout sur nos
téléphones et sur nos ordinateurs et
bien sûr on peut se demander si tout
cela est souhaitable c'est une question
absolument passionnante à laquelle j'ai
répondu quand je me suis enregistré mais
on me répond je me suis rendu compte que
la vie que j'ai donnée était quand même
vachement mon avis personnel et même si
je pense qu'ils mon avis personnel est
intéressant je pense qu'il n'a pas lieu
de le donner sur cinq forums du coup je
vous invite à si vous voulez l'entendre
à me le demande et si suffisamment de
personnes me le demande
j'essaierai de le mettre quelque part
sur l'internet mondial
j'espère que j'avais cette virtuel
vidéos d'actualité en fait j'aime pas
l'actualité donc j'aime pas réagir à
l'actualité
mais comment fait ça parle de réseaux de
neurones et d'intelligence artificielle
jeu sujet sur lequel je suis en train de
faire un documentaire vidéo
beaucoup plus complet entre autres sur
ça mais sur les mathématiques du be that
en général c'est un sujet donc que je
connais pour moi c'est pas un sujet
d'actualité c'est un sujet important de
recherche de sciences il se trouve que
actuellement il ya beaucoup d'avancé
dans ce domaine
mais même s'ils avaient pas lancer dans
ce domaine j'aurais aimé pouvoir en
parler est bon comme la qualité est là
donc je me suis dit moi je veux faire ça
un petit peu vite fait maintenant mais
il y aura des trucs beaucoup plus solide
beaucoup ne le fait
dans le documentaire à venir